c'est le moment de conclure notre série
d'entrevues avec les chefs des
principaux partis politiques ce soir
pauline marois nous l'avons rencontré au
parc lafontaine en fin d'après midi il y
a six semaines beaucoup beaucoup de gens
croyaient que madame marois et le parti
québécois voguait vers une victoire
facile la campagne a été beaucoup plus
difficile que prévu quelques questions
je vais poser là dessus et d'autres
sujets bien sûr la charte
voici l'entrevue mme marois bonjour
bonjour quand vous voyez certains matins
là l'urd la campagne est ce que vous
regrettez d'avoir déclenché cette
campagne je ne regrette jamais d'avoir
pris la décision qui s'avérerait la plus
pertinente à ce moment là et je me suis
retrouvé dans une situation vraiment de
blocage à l'assemblée nationale les
partis d'opposition voulaient nous
renverser mais ils nous ont tout
renversé comme vous auriez pu déposer
votre budget vous faire renverser puis
j'arrive été quitte pour votre loi vous
inquiéter son petit pelé ouvert comme je
le faisais moi je préférais prendre
l'initiative honnêtement nous avions
adopté un point très concret à pour les
québécois en matière d'emploi la charte
les enjeux étaient déjà bien connus
avant l'élection et sabha paraissait
important que les québécois puissent se
prononcer sur notre équipe par rapport à
une équipe quasi inexistence de chez
michou cuillère puisse se prononcer sur
nos orientations point sur ce que nous
défendons pour le québec ménard l emploi
la charte
quand même la loi que vous avez fait
voter à l'assemblée nationale moi je
sais j'ai ce petit clip sonore de votre
ministre bernard wilks a dit même en
situation de gouvernement minoritaire
nous allons respecter on n'a pas des
principes dans un campement à reims mais
attention c'est quand même créé est
inégal à ce moment là on se met dans une
situation de faiblesse puisque d'autres
peuvent nous renverser à n'importe quel
moment
au moment où eux ont de bonnes ondes et
sondages peut-être plus favorable envers
moi je crois dans un gouvernement
minoritaire
il faut se garder la possibilité de
déclencher comme gouvernement
une élection vous aviez d'ailleurs de
bons sondages à ce moment
parce que vous tout le monde disait
madame harel est elle là il faut qu'ils
gardent le ballon mais c'est ça sent bon
pour le pays mais on change complètement
mais c'est à dire que moi je comme
entrepôt et sondages mais c'est sûr que
c'est une campagne qui a pris une allure
différente parce que monsieur guarenas
couillard a décidé de faire peur aux
gens en leur faisant croire que c'était
une élection qui portait sur un
référendum
est ce que ça vous a surpris que
l'argumentaire sur le référendum
prennent autant dans la population un
peu étonné parce que comme pour moi
j'avais été très clair qu' il n'était
pas question de tenir un référendum à
court terme à moins que la population
québécoise soit jamais été très clair
voir venir mais la réaction des
québécois contrôle à votre ministre
lisée a dit ça m'a surpris le mouvement
de recul que les québécois en loup est
ce que ça nous a surpris mais et c'est à
dire que ça m'a pas étonné parce que
monsieur couillard dès le moment où on a
abordé cette question a voulu faire de
l'élection une élection qui portait sur
le référendum et il a fait peur aux gens
en élections mais pour ce choix de
revers de la main ce sujet il ya
probablement espèce de traumatisme par
rapport au référendum paisible pour ça
parce que tu es le conte veulent pas je
vois mais c'est pour ça que je leur ai
dit aux québécois que je le redis à
nouveau chez une femme déterminée ce
parce que les gens connaissent mais
c'est une femme capable d'écouter et
j'ai voulu dire autre chose
moi je crois que le québec serait mieux
servie si tu en as lu mais ces décisions
et qui ne laissait pas les décisions se
prendre à ottawa par monsieur un peu
mais moi je pop en hachant où le risque
d'erreur fait de perdre un référendum
alors si les québécois ne sont pas prêts
si les québécois n'en souhaite pas il
est évident qu on en tiendra pas je
pense qu'il faut pas être grand clerc
vous est-ce que vous en souhaitez dans
le prochain mandat et moi je
souhaiterais que les québécois soient de
près le plus rapidement possible à
prendre une telle décision mais encore
une fois je peux pas les bousculer
je peux pas les obliger à cela puis vous
dit on va prendre une décision qu'on va
sentir québécois seront prêts oui
comment vous prenez ça se décide
actuellement l'un bureau à regarder non
est-ce que les gens sont prêts restent
parce que c'est clair donc passés les
sondages une sondage
oui et non aussi on le sent quand les
gens font de la promotion d'un projet le
défunt demande un gouvernement de se
prononcer et si vous aviez et si qu'un
étranger ou n'a vieil ami que j'ai pas
vu de la crise est à vous appeler demain
marois d'après vous est ce qu'ils vont
en avoir un ou pas mais je lui dirais
exactement ce que je vous dis que vous
le savez pas que je ne sais pas donc
mais cependant ce que je sais c'est que
l'élection ne porte pas sur ça elle
porte sur le choix d'un gouvernement
la charpente sauf vous avez voulu faire
porter l'élection sur la charte c'était
votre reparti l enjeu principal vous
disiez avec nous une charte avec les
autres il n'y a pas de charte
ce matin encore on vous a posé la
question paul arcand se poser la
question est ce qu'il voit déjà que vont
perdre leur emploi des femmes vont
perdre leur emploi ils sont non plus
c'est pas très clair parce que le team 1
s'ils veulent garder le voile
elles vont perdre leur parle de
l'arrivée nous ne le souhaitons pas non
mais nous allons tout faire pour que
cela n'arrive pas n'oubliez pas que la
charte ya un an de transition dans la
fonction publique il y en a 3 4 dans les
les hôpitaux les écoles et 1 à sec dans
les municipalités
on va avoir le temps de travailler sur
cet enjeu là j'en suis persuadé mais je
voudrais pour revenir sur une autre
chose
l'injure la baisse continuelle des
avants parce que excusez moi mais c'est
pas clair dans un cp 1
une femme musulmane musulmane qui décide
moi je juge pour des raisons intimes je
veux pas landry multi mans elle va
devoir allant du cp attendez moi je
crois qu'une société et que des
personnes peuvent évoluer peuvent
changer dans la vie et c'est à ça qu'on
va travailler alors un endroit sont de
la paix sont gardés vienne patrick à la
fed toute cette période dans quatre
danses est qu on refera le point
s'il ya quelques cas on trouvera
sûrement des solutions et parce qu'en
plus on va faire autre chose
la charte elle va s'appliquer le
lendemain matin wall ou non la vote
c'est à dire pour ceux et celles qui
voudront entrer dans la fonction
publique ou qui voudront entrer au
service d'une garderie ceux qui sont
déjà là on va leur demander
progressivement on va travailler avec
elle et avec eux pour qu'on puisse
trouver une solution ici vous êtes élu
majoritaire est ce que vous excluez sur
cette question-là d'imposer à tous les
employés de l'état ce que vous excluez
de mettre de l'eau dans votre vin et de
dire bombay pour certaines catégories de
personnes par exemple dans le milieu
médical dans les gares de vie bon ok on
a on a compris on s'est peut-être pas
sur les principes fondamentaux et les
règles de base
on ne reculera pas vous n'allez pas
baisser la barre a passé là bas on va
plutôt trouver une façon d'accompagner
les gens de les appuyer de les aider de
les faire cheminer et je crois qu'on est
capable via ce que madame marois si vous
aviez un peu baisser la barre vous
seriez entendu claque facilement il vous
aurait aimé la part des devant votre
bureau à québec
j'avoue débarquant klein on dit que
c'est le seul enjeu ce pas le seul enjeu
bien d'autres jeux c'est l'emploi il ya
un autre enjeu c'est la langue et sur la
langue
on n'a pas réussi à s'entendre avec la
cac et surtout pas que les libéraux ne
veulent même pas en entendre parler
on a vu monsieur couillard ce qu'il
avait à dire sur la langue c'est
désastreux et désolant et décourageant
mais c'est ça d'accord mais vous n'êtes
pas répondre à la question pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas entendu avec les gens de la
calcul nous croyons pour une charte pas
exactement ce que vous voulez un chat
tueur est acceptable pour beaucoup parce
que nous croyons vraiment ce que nous
avons mis de l'avant ont la peau mis de
l'avant en faisant un bon ben on veut
or dans le fond on va dire une chose la
pression va modifier les règles passe à
côté
c'est important pour nous à leur
dernière question sur la chape cela j'ai
important pour mon regret pour les
libérer
on n'est pas passé loin bon n'est pas si
proche n'est pas très loin du carré
saint louis lui et jure algo des audois
points parce que vous pensez que gérald
incana fin qu'a fait tellement pour
essayer d'amener organisations vers
l'ouest québécois d'ouverture et les
nouveaux arrivants serait à l'aise avec
votre ex fléchirait pas par les égos des
vous comprendrez bien que je ne
révèlerai pas les demander ce que je
veux je comprends très bien ce que vous
voulez dire vous savez les québécois ont
toujours été très accueillants et nous
avons présenté un projet un engagement
entre autres au niveau de l'immigration
pour accélérer l'étude des dossiers pour
mieux reconnaître des professions de
gens qui viennent
d'autres pays il ya une entente avec la
france on pourrait en faire d'autres
sur d'autres professions avec les gens
du maghreb par exemple francisé est d
accompagner et quand on veut adopter une
charte de la laïcité c'est pour
clarifier les règles du bien vivre
ensemble
quelqu'un qui va venir d'asie d'afrique
et d'afrique d'amérique du sud va savoir
exactement dans quel état cette personne
va vivre quelles sont les règles sur la
langue et sur les rêves
quant à la laïcité de l'état et la
valeur qui est fondamental pour nous de
respect de l'égalité des hommes et les
femmes je vous écoute marmara vous êtes
vraiment là-dessus
j'avais vraiment la tête dure vraiment
vous êtes convaincu sur celles des ex
chef du parti québécois qui ont saisi
dès les séries us un méchant monsieur
parizeau geste du cev
mais si vous allez trop loin d'être
celui-là vous êtes mais nous avons eu
l'appui des faits du cas de la fonction
publique
nous avons eu l'appui de syndicats
devant vous persévérez l'âge de 5 ans
même si vous voyez le risque des gens
qui sont moins à l'aise dans votre wii
nous persévérons parce que nous pensons
que le choix et je congèle fut de ceux
ci convaincu de cela jusqu'au nonobstant
avant même d mais c'est à dire que le
nonobstant si on peut l'éviter on
l'évitera j'allais dit à quelques
reprises mais je ne voulais pas nous
empêcher l'intégrité je porte pour faire
on vous a posé 850 médiation la vie j'ai
une petite question pourquoi votre mari
claude blanchet et palais devant une
caméra pour s'expliquer non parce que je
crois que lui il ne fait pas de la
politique moi j'en fais et en plus il
avait fourni la uc procura où il ya
longtemps il ya eu ces procureurs qui
ont bien indiqué ce sa position et moi
je crois que c'était correct d'agir
comme ça vous savez j'ai le sentiment
que les gens veulent se venger
actuellement vous revoir parce que nous
avons été très durs à l'endroit des
entreprises
dès que nous sommes entrés au
gouvernement si celle-ci s'attendait à
quelques retours que ce soit parce que
des personnes auraient pu financer notre
parti politique
ce n'était pas le cas parce que jamais
jamais je ne vais accepter de tels lobé
alors y'en a qui ont eu la vie dure une
fois nous sommes revenus au gouvernement
il nous avons fait reculer la corruption
nous avons économisé déjà 240 millions $
au ministère des transports
alors on ne me fera pas de chantage les
gens ont vu seulement marois et vous
avez eu des projets de lois des lois et
cetera je pense que les gens peuvent
mesurer sa mais de dire que au parti
québécois jamais eu des prénoms rien une
fois on le rembourse et si nous les gens
disent paroisse non mais attention
peut-être que des gens ont utilisé des
prête-noms
mais nous jamais on va consoler la
chapeaute à louer mais jamais jamais on
a demandé à des gens de ramasser de
l'argent pour ensuite se faire
rembourser
ça c'est fondamental janvier quand le
parti libéral est au pouvoir lors
financement d'hommes
le nôtre est constat il doit avoir
quelques leçons à tirer de cela
madame marois la santé interdit aussi le
sujet ans quand ils ont fait des
interviews les gens à l'emploi
évidemment mais la santé le gouvernement
du québec a une emprise plus direct sur
l'emploi
c'est vrai la santé ce qu'on va
finalement voir des progrès parce que
vous disiez ça va
l'on vous avait pas promis de miracle en
quatre ans dont vous avez fait 18 mois
qui se comprend dans l'es12 d'enchaîner
les convainc revend continuer à agir là
où c'est important
d'abord pour les personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie on sait que si on peut
les aider demeurait à domicile avoir des
soins firme et de l'aide à domicile
elles vont moins venir fréquenter les
urgences elles ne vont pas aller dans
les centres d'hébergement elles vont
être plus heureuse chez elle et on va
donc diminuer la pression sur le système
de santé
cette exigence les airs les urgences le
temps d'attentes a reculé de presque
c'est pas beaucoup mais ce que nous
ferons je promets pas de miracle mon
époux miracle ce que nous font agir avec
les personnes âgées et les grecs
d'urgence n'y a pas de recette magique
tous ceux qui sont venus avant nous il
conclut monsieur couillard avait promis
lui que ce serait fini le temps
d'attentes je promets rien aux québécois
comme ça mais je leur promets que
progressivement
on va diminuer ce temps d'attentes on y
est déjà arrivé ils vont avoir accès à
un médecin de famille on est déjà sur la
très bonne voie et l'on va avoir un état
que je peux vous jurer mots si j'étais
milieu de la santé puis je sais ce que
ça veut dire que de vouloir rester c'est
un battant alors si vous étiez
minoritaires j'aurai fait tout chaud
pour toi et tout ça pour moi je souhaite
nous sommes l'élection a lieu le 7 avril
il reste encore quelques jours devant
nous et moi je suis confiante que la
population du québec va nous faire
confiance pour que nous dirigions un
gouvernement majoritaire le 7 avril
prochain en a marre bonne fin de
campagne
merci beaucoup au revoir puis soigner
votre si la wii joints des personnes
traversent remercie